nous accueillons notre invité du samedi
20 heures ce soir guy carlier
pour la vie l'amour le foot toujours en
compagnie de pierre moscovici
[Applaudissements]
les sens mais la mise
la dernière fois que j'ai devenu vous
travaillez avec bataille et fontaine et
vous expliquer que c'est des mecs
intelligents et sympa bataille et
fontaine pourquoi pas les deux connards
de y'a que la vérité qui compte donc
vous il ya là il se soit venu dire que
cauet un doctorant en physique nucléaire
non
[Musique]
gears bonsoir vous publiez la vie
l'amour le foot chez jean claude
gawsewitch vous êtes chroniqueur sur
france 2 à scat 2 le dimanche à 17h50 en
fait j'ai de payer pour lire l'équipe
critiquer domenech ce que des millions
de français font gratuitement tous les
jours vous ne pouvez pas imaginer à quel
point c'est vrai quand même aller au
stade je voyais thierry rolland au parc
des princes il était déjà là quand on
était petit il ressemble à darry cowl tu
sais à l'époque et je me disais ce
mec-là fais le plus beau métier du monde
vient parler de foot le dimanche à la
télé et quand on m'a proposé ça je suis
c'est bien alors on peut se demander
quelle est votre légitimité pour
distribuer des bons et des mauvais
points vous n'êtes pas journaliste
enfin sportifs en tous les cas vous
n'êtes pas footballeurs de haut niveau
non mais attends juste une chose tu vas
pas prendre un footballeur pour écrire
donc
quand on aime on comprend vous êtes
passionné de foot mais vraiment il est
fou de foot depuis votre plus tendre
enfance c'est souvent cette phrase d'un
manager anglais qui disait le foot n'est
pas une question de vie ou de mort c'est
bien plus que ça or là vous faites pas
partie guy de ce qui jusqu en 98 prenez
le foot pour un sport de beauf 1 vous
vous souvenir remonte au noir et blanc
votre premier ballon en cuir vous dormi
avec ce qu'est ce qui est intéressant
dans votre bouquin en fait c'est si vous
souvenir personnel sont universels dire
qu'on a tous eu le vieux con à lunettes
qui binet son jardin et qui rendait pas
le ballon quand il tombait chez lui
c'est des images qu'on a tous dans la
tête ça c'est là où c'est fort ouais bon
départ vous êtes fan de monaco à cause
d'un joueur qui s'applique qu'à relier
tanger à croire qu'il était mon frère
est totalement faux évidemment les mecs
au collège ceux qui connaissaient pas
mon nom des autres classes m'appelait
monaco je n'arrêtais pas de soul et tout
le monde et miracle c'est l'année où
monaco réalise le doublé avec une équipe
magique qui fait le jeu que j'ai jamais
vu depuis d'aisé réunit tous ils ont 72
ans je les ai fait venir en aide et j'ai
fait un déjeuner avec eux à l'hôtel
crillon et quand je les ai vus sortir du
minibus ils ont 72 ans [ __ ] on aurait
cru des juniors les gars ils sont là et
genre avait amené mes photos pendant le
repas et je leur disais ah tu te
rappelles ce match-là contre l'inter de
milan et le gars me racontait sac entre
cinq ans après sa maladie je te dis que
c'est un jeu d'enfant c'est
alors
métier pas fan de l'équipe de france
1998 et en 2000 vous trouvez qu'elle
avait un style trop défensif vous dites
c'est comme un jour de pluie traversée
des éclairs de génie de zidane je me
souviens que ce qui m'avait choqué c'est
le lendemain de cette finale gagnée en
98 où tout le monde titrait la plus ces
conneries la france black blanc beur
rien mais bon et et j'avais moi entendu
un commentaire d'un joueur italien je
crois que c'était maldini qui disait en
parlant de l'italie réputée pour son
catenaccio son jeu défensif nous avons
enfanter un monstre en bas du psg vous
dites que le psg bien évidemment
appartient à un fonds de placement
colonies dirigé en france par bazin
ils ont complètement con les retraités
texan qui placent leurs économies dans
un club où joue rothen et bourillon ne
fait vraiment rien au foot je détestais
le au parc des princes j'y suis allé la
dernière fois justement parce que
sochaux joué franchement mené à sochaux
parce que là c'est le foot des ouvriers
c'est le fameux sympathique et le plus
beau là le talent le sait la même voie
là le public du psg je parle pas de tout
le public non les plus tristes
samu et quand je vois les gars qui
ensuite sorte encadrés par les crs
cheval un sécheur vraiment su chan alors
on est le cas alors anelka voulez mais
il ya une chose qui est incroyable c'est
qu'évidemment comme les journalistes
sportifs ont besoin des mecs pour venir
sur les plateaux depuis des années il ya
des choses qu'on dit pas moi je m'en
fous j'arrive je suis chroniqueur ça
leur fout la merde parce que les gars ne
veulent plus venir à stade 2 mais je
veux dire il faut quand même bien dire
que depuis des années on voit des
joueurs murés dans leur mp3 qui font la
gueule qui signent pas d'autographe ça
change avec des gens comme ribéry des
pour le coup très généreux très heureux
d'être là qui joue qui me tue voix mais
anelka tu as l'impression qu'il dérange
dans sa partie de playstation
dû descendre du bus c'est beaucoup aux
vitres teintées et qui calcule pas les
mômes dans les attentions l'une est 5h
la même chose si c'était pas ouais
auprès des consultantes dit avant les
anciens joueurs il ouvre à un pmu
douille donner leur avis sur les maths
jours alors se trouve que ça plaît aux
penaltys vaut rien et vous dites
maintenant eh ben ils font ça à la télé
quoi parce qu'ils aient poussé c'est les
gars qu'on plusieurs casquettes comme
jean michel larqué tu vas dire sur tf1
comme tf1 et partenaire de l'équipe de
france y taille pas trop marie dit on se
pose des questions puis après que le
retrouve sur rmc il aida
vous aimez pas beaucoup des champs comme
chroniqueur quoi il dit y a pire qu'un
match du psg
c'est un match du psg commentée par dc
mais est ce que tu te souviens à
l'alexandra dans une famille je suis
commencer toutes ses phrases par bombay
puis c'est comme certaines filles du sud
et bien des champs ils commencent toutes
ses phrases comme alexandra bombe et je
crois que vous parlez de zidane alors
évidemment bouchité cette anecdote que
citroën dans son bouquin c'est zidane
qui fauche rothen par derrière et qui
lui lit relève toi fils de [ __ ] oui
c'est sûr ça m'a jamais grâce à zidane
c'est pas un dieu c'est un dieu balle au
pied ainsi l'été pareil
intellectuellement ce serait dieu doit
donc c'est pas possible ce qui me gêne
ce qui me gêne c'est quand monsieur
danone ou
generali téléphone à rothaine ou à son
éditeur en dix ans ce serait bien pour
l'image que zidane donne aux enfants
c'est à dire une image de dieu n'est pas
cette anecdote dans son livre on peut
pas faire ça au nom du business voilà
maintenant alors thierry roland à vous
l'adorez tirer roland vie c'est comme
johnny c'est comme journaux hier ouvre
ppda voilà les auditions la nourrit
toujours ces mecs là ne peut pas dire
puis les aimes ou tu les aimes pas
sérieux quand elle est quand même dit un
truc énorme quand il dit c'est un match
trop important pour le confier un
arbitre tunisia bergamelli pas pour
l'union
chose limites sur 50 ans de carrière
soit c'est un type thierry roland qui
gagne à être connu c'est un type qu'une
éducation anglaise l'harmattan c'est pas
un blaireau donc quand il joue le beauf
ce qui lui arrive assez souvent il fait
exprès bien sûr
voilà du coup malgré tout il n'y a quand
même de temps en temps chez ce type qui
assurément talentueux côté beauf un
support très c'est votre problème quoi
dont vous êtes trop cultivé pas assez
bof ça m'arrive aussi
ça fait du bien
ouais mais avait lui bien quand le
gardien dégage de crier oh hisse [ __ ]
ça fait des petits rituels non mais
comme gardien dégage est alors last but
not least évidemment domenech alors
qu'ils refusent de venir sur france 2
tant que vous êtes là que j'ai une
théorie sur domenech vous dites c'est
très utile qui est domenech parce que
c'est comme les ceintures de plomb pour
l'entraînement le jour où il sera plus
là on sera libéré en gagnera oui c'est à
dire par ses compos d'équipé on l'a vu
là contre la lituanie il fait rentrer le
lieu d'où la fin qui donne des handicaps
à l'équipe et après quand il refait un
un coaching normal il fait rentrer on
dit ah beh il a fait un bon coach zahoui
rémy les naseaux début après cela il a
quand même des onze joueurs parmi les
meilleurs du monde et avec ça il n'y a
pas de y apporte un jeu y'a pas de joie
de jouer il n'y a rien donc le jour
outre un mec qui fera juste cette sauce
là ça sera génial à voir donc voilà
vraiment
tu sais ce qu'il te reste à faire en
dedans c'est un livre formidable
vraiment vous aimez vous adorerez le
football et et ça transpire bat donc
toutes les pages vues et toi si tu t'es
foot moi je suis très foot mais moi je
soutiens les girondins de bordeaux
depuis toujours depuis qu'ils ont
gourcuff laisse abuser les burqa il
surtout sans rien il est très beau
garçon c'est un beau gars 126,38 whisky
lui régulièrement sélectionné ce pur on
on n'y va que pour ça d'ailleurs
philippe besson oublie son dernier roman
vient aux fondamentaux
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux